hundreds of military dogs are deployed
overseas to help the United States and
military many put themselves in harm's
way to protect the men and women who
follow them into combat today five
canine veterans will receive the
American Humane Louis Pope life canine
medal of courage it honors their service
to their country chip Reid is on Capitol
Hill with the important role the dogs
play in the field and in the lives of
troops chip good morning well good
morning here they are for retired US
military heroes they are starting at the
other end they are ranger Kappa Alpha
and coffee and we got to spend some
special time with coffee for most of a
day she was always with me side by side
my mentality was I needed her just as
much as she needed me she can't get me
through i'ma get her through army
sergeant James Bennett served with
coffee a chocolate Labrador Retriever by
his side for almost 10 years they did
three tours in Afghanistan Coffee was an
explosive detection dog
sniffing out bombs and facing danger
head-on as the units first line of
defense she's never lost a soldier ever
we've never had to go anywhere and say
okay some happened she's never lost
anything she's saved a lot of lives yes
sir including perhaps yours no I know
her life
did she come under fire yeah too many
times too many times many times because
they know how valuable she is so they
target her yeah they do uh there's been
several instances where she was targeted
dogs like coffee are valuable to the
military for their loyalty their courage
and their extraordinary sense of smell
over 1,600 dogs are currently serving in
the US and around the world 34 have been
killed in action during the wars in Iraq
and Afghanistan Bennett says through
three deployments coffee became much
more than a dog even more than a best
friend do you consider her our hero I
consider her an angel an angel now
Wow this one she brought me home you
think you would have survived three
tours in Afghanistan without her Lord
girls his wife Lindsay encouraged him to
nominate coffee for the canine medal of
courage what does this dog mean to you
she is the reason I have my husband
there was a couple of times where I
didn't hear from him for a couple days
and it was panic okay
you get that tight feeling and because
you always hear things on the news and
you don't know did you feel better just
knowing he was with coffee yes coffee
now lives with the Bennett's and their
three kids Talon Trinity and Madeline
for ten years of service
love is coffee's endless reward who here
loves coffee raise your hand why do you
love coffee so much home from
Afghanistan to them coffee is a member
of the family and at 13 years old they
know she is approaching her final years
we have 17 years of marriage right now
and we wouldn't have that ya know her we
wouldn't have the three kids we have
without her she's really giving me my
life have it now you know she's getting
to give me a chance to enjoy my kids
grow up and enjoy my time my wife you
know I want her to enjoy those this last
part she's earned it
okay so you've met coffee let's take a
look at the other three first we have
Alfie here Alfie served in Afghanistan
he now works as a bomb sniffer with the
TSA then you have CAPA served in the
Navy went to Iraq and Afghanistan and
protected the President of the United
States and then we have Ranger who
served with the US Marines in Iraq and
Afghanistan now you may be wondering
about the tennis balls well the truth is
we're told that if you train dogs with
food they get a little bored with it
after a while but they never get tired
of this Nora yeah terrific story
congratulations to all of those yes and
they only they were smiling
I thought Lindsey Bennett raised a good
point where she said we didn't hear
anything for two days often wonder when
we poured a story on the news that a
soldier has died
it says two other families who are
waiting and then you see on the other
side they didn't hear anything for two
days but they had coffee it's so great
it worked out okay yeah you called me
yes thank you